all right and of course to get into the
home games for the raiders fans show
proof of covet 19 vaccinations they can
use an app if they're fully immunized
but everyone else has to go through
alternate screening process orgo mana is
live at allegiance stadium with how this
all played out today or go
well christian first of all the fans
here raiders fans are in denial one
woman told me that the raiders did not
lose so that's one thing there but
taking a look behind me some fans are
still leaving allegiant stadium right
now and as you mentioned the covered
vaccine protocols are still in place
many fully vaccinated raiders fans use
the clear app and fans who are partially
vaccinated or underage and cannot use
the app go through a tent where they
show their id and vaccine cards and
while this these
these options have had past hiccups with
both entry systems things seem to run
smoothly today
the silver and black out in full force
to watch the las vegas raiders take on
the chicago bears but before watching
all the action unfold fans have to show
proof of covet 19 vaccination those
fully vaccinated can use the clear
health pass most are happy with it even
with minor connection issues works fine
the only problem sometimes around here
because everybody's accessing the
internet at the same time back of the
line is on the next street over fans who
are not fully vaccinated got a vaccine
not supported by the clear app or are 12
to 13 years old and unable to be added
to the app come here to the alternate
screening tent in lot b despite the
relatively new process and the huge
crowd fans agree things are running
smoothly it was quicker than what you
think it is
it's a long line but it's quick it was a
lot faster than i expected it to be but
fans have different opinions about
having to show proof at all some say
it's important i think it's good for
everyone
just because you should check if
everything is legit instead of just
going off someone's word while others
are doing it out of necessity not a big
fan of it but i'm here i'll do what i
have to do so i watch the game but not a
fan of it all and we asked some young
fans not eligible for the shot yet about
the vaccine would you have gotten it
yeah yeah and why
to go to raider games
now for fans who are eligible for the
vaccine but have not gotten it yet there
is the option to get your first shot
here on site before heading inside but
they as well as partially vaccinated
fans will be required to wear masks
reporting live at allegiance stadium
tonight orco mana live local now